REPUBLICANS DEMANDING ANSWERS
WHILE THE WHITE HOUSE REFUSES TO
TALK ABOUT PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
CONTROVERSIAL JULY PHONE CALL
WITH THEN AFGHAN PRESIDENT
GHANI.
WE'RE GETTING NEW DETAILS ABOUT
THAT LEAKED TRANSCRIPT WHERE THE
PRESIDENT PRESSURED THE AFGHAN
LEADER TO SAY THE TALIBAN WASN'T
WINNING.
GHANI REPORTEDLY TELLING BIDEN,
MR. PRESIDENT, WE'RE FACING A
FULL SCALE INVASION.
REPUBLICANS NOW WANT THE FULL
TRANSCRIPT RELEASED AND SLAMMING
PRESIDENT BIDEN OVER THE PHONE
CALL.
>> IT'S ONE EXAMPLE OF THE
DISASTROUS MISCALCULATIONS THAT
BROUGHT US TO WHERE WE ARE NOW
WITH HUNDREDS OF AMERICANS LEFT
BEHIND IN AFGHANISTAN BECAUSE OF
JOE BIDEN'S EXECUTION OF HIS
DECISION TO RECALL.
>> THEY DON'T CALL HIM QUIT PRO
JOE ABOUT NOTHING.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
THIS IS THE FACT THAT HE HAD TO
LIE MEANS HE KNEW SIX WEEKS AGO
THAT THINGS WERE GOING TO GO
BAD.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> HE DIDN'T ADDRESS THIS
STRATEGY.
HE DIDN'T WARN AMERICANS IN THAT
COUNTRY TO LEAVE.
>> MEANTIME WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY JEN PSAKI IS BEING
CALLED A HYPOCRITE FOR REFUSING
TO GIVE DETAILS ABOUT THE CALL.
>> WAS THE PRESIDENT PUSHING A
FALSE NARRATIVE IN THAT CALL
WITH THE AFGHAN PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK IT'S CLEAR.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO INTO DETAILS
OF A PRIVATE CONVERSATION.
WHAT WE SAW OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST FEW MONTHS IS A
COLLAPSE IN LEADERSHIP.
THAT WAS HAPPENING EVEN BEFORE
GHANI LEFT THE COUNTRY.
>> GREG?
WE'LL GET TO YOU IN A SECOND.
BACK IN 2019, PSAKI CARED A LOT
ABOUT PHONE CALLS WHEN IT CAME
TO TRUMP'S CHAT WITH THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
WHAT DID YOU UTTER, GREG?
>> WHEN THEY SAID IT WAS A
COLLAPSE OF LEADERSHIP, I WAS
TRYING TO SEE WHO HE WAS
REFERRING TO.
>> YOU WANT TO CONTINUE?
>> SURE.
WHY IS THIS LIE IMPORTANT?
IT KIND OF TELLS YOU HOW REGULAR
LYING IS IN THIS PROCESS.
THAT WE'VE BEEN LIED TO FOR SO
LONG.
HOW CAN A WAR LAST 20 YEARS?
IT CAN IF IT'S TOLERABLE TO A
POINT OF INVISIBILITY.
WE'VE HAD 20 SUPER BOWLS OF
THIS.
20 CHRISTMASS.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
THE SECRET TO A LONG WAR IS
SETTLING IN AND MAKING IT MILDLY
OKAY THROUGH FIBBING.
EVERYTHING IS GOING WELL.
THE WAR IS GREAT.
EVERYTHING IS FINE.
IT'S THE LIE THAT KEPT THIS
THING GOING.
HE DID -- HE DID -- WHAT HE DID
IS UNETHICAL.
IS IT IMPEACHMENT LEVEL?
I DON'T THINK SO BUT I'M NOT A
LIBERAL.
I'M NOT A DEMOCRAT.
I DON'T WORK AT CNN WHERE
EVERYTHING IS IMPEACHABLE.
WHAT IS IT?
TURN ABOUT THE FAIR PLACE?
PEOPLE SHOULD BE SHOUTING FOR
IMPEACHMEN
IMPEACHMENT.
IT'S JUST ANOTHER SIGN THAT THE
ENTIRE PICTURE WAS NEVER EVER
TOLD.
IT'S NEVER TOLD TO US.
THAT'S WHY I THINK AFGHANISTAN
FELL SO FAST BECAUSE THESE HAPPY
LITTLE STORIES WERE FOR US AND
NOT THEM.
>> WILL, LISTENING TO JEN PSAKI,
YOU DON'T RESPOND TO A QUESTION
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A GOOD ANSWER.
SHE EBB DOESN'T HAVE A GOOD
ANSWER FOR THIS.
>> BECAUSE SHE'S FULL OF
HYPOCRISY.
IT'S HARD TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
WHEN YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH
YOURSELF FROM A PREVIOUS TIME
PERIOD.
YOU BROUGHT UP IMPEACHMENT.
IF THERE WERE PRESIDENT TRUMP,
WOULD THERE BE A PUSH FOR
IMPEACHMENT?
WE KNOW THE ANSWER IS YES.
IF THE PHONE CALL DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IF IT WAS THE AFGHAN DEBACLE
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP?
WOULD THERE BE IMPEACHMENT?
ABSOLUTELY.
A STORY TO DO LATER.
IF TWO TOP FDA EXECUTIVES
RESIGNED UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP,
WOULD THERE BE A CONTROVERSY?
YES.
CLEARLY WE'RE NOT PLAYING BY THE
SAME RULES A YEAR AGO.
QUICKLY ON THE LIE.
WE NEED TO LAY OUT HOW CYNICAL
THIS IS.
WHAT THIS REVEALS IS PRESIDENT
BIDEN KNEW THE NATURE OF WHAT
WAS GOING DOWN.
HE MADE DECISIONS KNOWING THE
POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES.
WE CAN PLAY THE DEGREE GAMES.
WASN'T SURE HOW BAD IT WOULD BE.
HE MADE A CALCULATION TO ACCEPT
THAT CHAOS.
I THINK HE MADE THAT CALCULATION
BECAUSE HE THOUGHT HE COULD PLAY
THE BLAME GAME AND LAY IT OFF ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THAT HAS FAILED.
THE LIE FAILED.
>> THE POLL NUMBERS, BRING THESE
IN.
OH, AS THEY DROP TO 43% IN THE
NEW POLL.
THE NPR OF PBS NEWS HOUR POLL.
THE FACTS ARE WE KNOW THAT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY WARNED
PRESIDENT BIDEN EVEN BEFORE HE
ANNOUNCED THE WITHDRAWAL IN
APRIL THAT THE AFGHAN NATIONAL
ARMY WOULD COLLAPSE.
SO AGAIN, WHY THE COVER-UP?
WHAT IS THE POLITICAL GAIN?
CLEARLY THAT WAS THE MOTIVE.
>> SO FAR WE WON'T KNOW WHAT THE
POLITICAL GAIN IS FOR QUITE SOME
TIME UNTIL WE GET CLOSER TO THE
MID-TERMS.
THIS IS A HUGE BOTTOM ISSUE.
WE HAVE THE TEXAS ABORTION CASE
THAT CAME DOWN.
THAT HAS ACTIVATED THE LIBERALS
THAT SAY THIS IS THE RIGHT --
>> I THINK -- GO AHEAD.
THEN I'LL INTERRUPT YOU.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY -- I'M
EXCITED.
GIVE ME 40 SECONDS.
OKAY.
THE POLL NUMBERS ARE OBVIOUSLY
SLIPPING.
THEY'RE NOT AS WELL AS PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S WERE AT THIS POINT.
PRESIDENT OBAMA NEVER HIT THIS
POINT UNTIL THE THIRD YEAR OF
HIS PRESIDENCY.
TRUMP AND BIDEN ARE STRUGGLING
MORE THAN OBAMA WAS NECESSARILY.
TO THE POINT ABOUT THIS PHONE
CALL AND THE COVER-UP OF IT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ASKED FOR A
PERSONAL FAVOR FROM THE LEADER
OF ANOTHER COUNTRY.
HE DIDN'T SAY SOMETHING TO
ZELENSKY ABOUT HAVING ANYTHING
TO DO WITH DIPLOMATIC
RELATIONSHIPS.
HE ASKED HIM TO DIG UP DIRT SO
HE COULD WIN AN ELECTION THAT IS
WHY THAT IS IMPEACHABLE.
IF BIDEN HAD SAID, HEY,
PRESIDENT GHANI, SAY EVERYTHING
IS GOING WELL AND IF YOU COULD
DIG UP DIRT ON TOM COTTON, HE'S
GOTTING HOT, HE MIGHT BE RUNNING
IN 2024, WE WOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
EVERY LIBERAL WOULD BE FOR THAT.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
I LISTENED TO ANDY McCARTHY THIS
MORNING.
HE SAID I DON'T SEE ANYTHING
WRONG WITH THIS CALL BETWEEN
BIDEN AND GHANI HERE.
>> IT'S SO --
>> IT'S NOT ABUSE OF THE OFFICE.
>> THE CALL ITSELF IS KEEPLY
TROUBLING GIVEN THE FACT THAT
BIDEN HAS LIED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ABOUT WHAT WENT DOWN BLAMING
EVERYBODY BUT HIMSELF FOR
LITERALLY THE DEATH OF 13
AMERICAN TROOPS, SERVICE
MEMBERS.
THAT'S WHAT IS SO APPALLING IS.
THERE'S A NEED, WHETHER IT'S
TRUE OR NOT, THERE'S A NEED TO
PROJECT A DIFFERENT PICTURE,
WHAT IS HE IS STILL DOING EVEN
AFTER THE FACT.
>> IT GETS TO WILL'S POINT.
WE KNOW IF THIS WAS THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION, PEOPLE WOULD BE
OUTRAGED.
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE OUTRAGED AND
RIGHTLY ARE THAT WE LOST 13
PEOPLE THAT ARE BRAVES AND
SERVICE TO THIS COUNTRY.
THE REACTION WOULD BE OBVIOUSLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA AND HOW IT WAS HANDLED.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T LIKE
TO BE PLAYED FOR SUCKERS.
THAT'S REFLECTED IN THE POLLS.
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO TELL YOU
ONE THING WHETHER IT'S SOMETHING
ELSE AND COVID AND FRENCH
LAUNDRY.
PEOPLE HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
VETTING.
DO WE KNOW PEOPLE ARE BEING
THOROUGHLY VETTED AS THEY
SHOULD?
I GOT A MESSAGE FROM A FORMER
PILOT THAT FLIES COMMERCIAL.
FLEW A BIG JET OUT OF THERE.
HE SAID WE THOUGHT WE WERE ON
THIS GREAT HUMANITARIAN MISSION.
WHEN WE GOT TO THE STATES, WE
WERE STUCK FOR HOURS ON THE
TARMAC OUTSIDE D.C. BECAUSE
THESE PEOPLE HADN'T BEEN VETTED.
WE HAD TO SEAT THERE WITH CRYING
BABIES AND PEOPLE THAT HAD NOT
EAT OR DRINK.
THEY WEREN'T TESTED FOR COVID
EITHER.
WHEN YOU DON'T TELL PEOPLE THE
FULL TRUTH AND NOW THEY'RE FULLY
VETTED, THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT EVERYTHING YOU
SAY.
>> WHY WOULD YOU LEAVE HUNDREDS
OF REPORTERS BEHIND AND
TRANSLATORS BEHIND IF THIS WAS
PLANNED?
A COUPLE MORE THINGS.
SOMEBODY LEAKED THIS TRANSCRIPT.
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT ARE PISSED
OFF WITHIN THIS ADMINISTRATION.
DON'T YOU EXPECT IT MORE AND
MORE OF THIS WILL COME OUT?
>> YEAH.
IT'S -- IT'S JUST WEIRD.
IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW
WE'VE ABANDONED OUR AFGHAN
ALLIES ESPECIALLY.
ALL YOU CAN SAY IS WHAT DID YOU
EXPECT FROM A RACIST COUNTRY RUN
BY A RACIST PRESIDENT?
OH, I THOUGHT I WAS AT CNN AND
TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD SAY.
>> YOU HAVE TO THINK IN
WASHINGTON, PEOPLE WILL START TO
TURN ON EACH OTHER.
THE PENTAGON, THE WHITE HOUSE,
THE INTEL COMMUNITY ARE ALL
LEAKING.
NOBODY WANTS TO GET THROWN UNDER
THE BUS.
I PREDICT MORE LEAKS TO COME.
>> ONE MORE THING TO SAY.
YOU LOOK HAT THIS TRANSCRIPT.
IT SHOWS JOE BIDEN VERY MUCH IN
CHARGE OF WHAT WAS GOING ON.
HE'S NOT THE CREAM OF WHEAT
SLURPING COGNITIVE --
>> REMEMBER SHE SAID THAT.
>> DON'T KNOCK CREAM OF WHEAT.